matière de production la france
s'engagera sur la construction d'une
première tranche premier palier de six
réacteurs enisa l'étude immédiate de
huit autres réacteurs
la puissance solaire sera multiplié par
dix et cinquante parc éolien en mer
seront déployés d'ici 2050 la stratégie
de production que je souhaite porter
pour la nation repose au fond sur trois
axes continuer les investissements en
réduction de consommation
avoir un déploiement de renouvelables
massif reposant sur le solaire l'éolien
en mer et le lien terrestre avec les
objectifs que je viens de rappeler et la
production de nucléaire avec la mise en
oeuvre immédiate d'un nouveau proche
d'un nouveau plan de construction de
réacteurs
premier objectif pour travailler plus
c'est le plein emploi cet objectif est
atteignable il consiste à faire dans les
cinq ans qui viennent ce que nous avons
fait dans les cinq ans qui viennent de
s'écouler nous transformerons aussi pôle
emploi en le transformant en france
travaillent ce qui est un changement
profond et je veux saluer l'engagement
vraiment tous les salariés de pôle
emploi mais l'idée est sur la base de ce
que nous avons lancés ces dernières
années avec le service public
d'insertion à l'emploi c'est de réussir
à l'échelle d'un territoire de mettre en
commun tous les savoir faire et les
compétences
celle de pôle emploi celle de nos
régions de nos départements des communes
des missions locales il ya une trop
grande segmentation de toutes celles et
ceux qui accompagnent le retour à
l'emploi la réforme que je souhaite
mener c'est
d'augmenter l'âge légal progressivement
comme on l'a toujours fait d'ailleurs
avec
un système de trim est progressif mais
donc de mener cet âge légal jusqu'à 65
ans de prendre en compte les carrières
longues
ce sera un sujet de négociation mais
celles et ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler très tôt faut le prendre en
compte le prendre en compte les
questions d'invalidité et de pouvoir de
la manière la plus individuelle possible
prendre en compte aussi la réalité des
métiers et des tâches pour avoir un
système qui est juste il y aura dans
cette réforme l'obligation de consacrer
15 à 20 heures par semaine pour une
activité permettant d'aller vers
l'insertion professionnelle cette
formation en insertion soit d'emploi et
être mieux accompagnés de dire y'a pas
simplement une prestation mais aussi un
accompagnement et au fond ce que je
souhaite faire avec le cette réforme du
rsa c'est exactement ce que nous sommes
en train de déployer depuis quelques
semaines avec le contrat d'engagement
jeunes pour les 18 25 je souhaite qu'on
puisse mettre en place ce que
j'appellerais la solidarité à la source
on a fait le prélèvement à la source
formidable innovation de simplicité de
lutte contre la fraude c'est ce qu'on a
lancé depuis 2018 c'est un travail
titanesque il a été conduit par monsieur
lenglart
demandé un gros travail de toutes les
associations beaucoup d'élus c'est au
fond de pouvoir dire le rsa la prime
d'activité les appelle les allocations
familiales tous ces dispositifs qui sont
très segmenté avec des logiques qui ne
sont pas les mêmes de revenu de
référence avec ensuite du coût des
trappes des situations ubuesques qu'on
connaît que à juste titre
souvent vous dénoncez en disant c'est du
coup des mécanismes qui n'incite pas à
reprendre l'activité parce que si je
reprends deux heures d'activité ou trois
heures d'activités je perds tes led qui
rendent notre système illisible injuste
nous allons les réformes et les
simplifier pour mettre en place cette
solidarité à la source 7 nous recrutons
50 mille infirmer aides soignants nous
renforcerons aussi les contrôles parce
que nous avons vu dans la période
récente l'importance de ce sujet à la
fois pour des personnes qui vivent dans
les établissements mais on a un besoin
d'investissement en personnel et donc
j'assume le recrutement de 50 mille
infirmiers aides-soignants et nous avons
besoin de renforcer les contrôles ce que
nous avons commencé à faire et qui sera
renforcée dans les cinq années qui
viennent si les françaises et les
français me font confiance pour pouvoir
justement lutter contre les pratiques
inhumaines dégradantes que nous ne
saurions accepter
[Musique]
oh